Hello
inaheim.
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in
which literally translates to the
concise, the abbreviated,
the abbreviated book on
understanding the Sunnah and the
Quran.
And as we've mentioned many times
before, this is really an
abbreviation
or it is a summary of
authored by say
the cha the book of fasting. Here
we are now at the chapter regarding
the obligation of fasting upon
witnessing the crescent of Ramadan.
[Silence]
Now this chapter is very important for
us to pay attention to. We are going to
be discussing the principles
of when Ramadan really starts, when any
month really starts. This chapter
speaks mainly about Ramadan but any
crescent of any month is affirmed in
the following way. Now this discussion
is a discussion that's important for us
to understand
in the sense of where
do we get our guidelines for the
beginning of the month?
How do we know legislatively shan
when a month begins and when a month
ends? when a month enters and when the
previous exits. This is important for us
to know in that
sense. However, this is not a
discussion
that is for the individual
Muslim to have with one another with
respect to when they begin fasting and
when they end their fasting. The
ultimate
guideline for when a person begins to
fast and when a person breaks his fast
is when the majority of his community
fast or break their fast.
The actual moon,
the moon itself, the crescent,
it is not the actual month.
It is a sign of the month.
Do we understand that concept? The
crescent itself, this is a a discussion
which is debated by the scholars of
fk. The correct opinion is that
the crescent itself is not the month of
Ramadan.
The month of Ramadan is indicated
by the crescent.
You might say, well, okay, what what
does that have to do with anything? This
is important because
the name of the month in the Arabic
language, we call a month in Arabic,
what? Shah sha. And what does the word
sha actually mean?
[Silence]
this root word
in the Arabic language it means that
which is well known that which is
prominent that which which is accepted
and mass that which is
famous or known or accepted. That's what
the actual meaning is. And so because of
that, the month does not commence until
that name takes its takes its meaning.
Until the month is known and accepted
as the month has commenced, it has not
commenced yet.
Based on that, what does that mean? That
means that hypothetically
if a person were to see the crescent
for Ramadan, let's say they see it by
themselves and they go back to their,
you know, the town, the the,
you know, imam of the town or the
council or what have you and they say,
"Hey, I saw the crescent." And they say
well you know they do not trust his
sight for whatever reason. There could
be many reasons and they do not see it
for themselves. And so hence he is the
only person who has seen it and the only
person in his whole community that has
witnessed the crescent. However the
month has not been acknowledged as
commencing yet. Does the person fast
that day by himself while everybody else
breaks his fast? No. The fah tell us
that he does not fast until everybody
else fasts. There is no situation
in which one person or two people or a
pocket of people a minority are fasting
amongst the majority of their community.
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
said
[Silence]
he says
and it's a narration we will get to in
this chapter
fasting starts when you all fast
together
and breaking your Fast happens when you
all break your fast together.
And the Eid of and slaughtering happens
when you all slaughter.
When the people stand on Arafa, that's
Arafa.
If it were hypothetically that everyone
stood on tomorrow, it is not Arafa until
the people stand there. Why? Because the
crescent itself is not the month. The
crescent is an indicator of the
beginning of the month. Legislatively
the month begins when it becomes common
knowledge.
When it becomes common knowledge we all
understand this. So if we were to follow
these guidelines, these guidelines of
the prophet himself sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and these are the statements of
imbu
himself
himself where they have posited in
their works and in their fatawa that
hypothetically a man were to see the
crescent on his own and it were not
largely accepted, he would not fast and
it is still the month of Shaan until
everyone fasts or until it becomes
common knowledge because that's even the
name of the month itself
takes its name sake from from that
acknowledgment amongst the people and
this is really an important point it
goes to something else and that is that
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
when he commanded things the month
of Ramadan, when he commanded things
and Hajj and so forth, the Jahya had
played around with the calendar.
The Jah the time of Jahyah, they had
something called a nit. And then nit was
something that they did where they
fudged the
calculations for the months and years
so that they could wiggle in a little
bit extra war during the sacred months
so that they could fit in a little bit
more extra blood and a little bit extra
activities that they deemed to be
haram during those sacred months. So
what did they do? They started to edge
into the month and take away from the
month, delay the month and postpone the
month until the calendar was so off keel
that it only reset itself during the
last Hajj of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. So we think about that in
the ninth year in the 10th year after
hijra that is when the calendar happened
to be reset.
So what does that mean? Does that mean
all the previous months of Ramadan were
off and wrong? Does that mean that their
fasting wasn't accepted? Of course not.
Why? Because the month is when it is
acknowledged by the people. It is not
the actual crescent itself. Imagine
people are in a dungeon. Prisoners in a
dungeon. The scholars have discussed
this as well. Prisoners in a dungeon.
They have no access to you know
seeing the sky or the moon or the stars
or anything. And they want to make
things like
they want to fast the month of Ramadan.
And so they start to make a calculation.
Those calculations are not going to be
very accurate, are they? However, is
their fasting and is there and
everything else accepted entirely? Yes.
Why? Because
is not the crescent.
Ash the month is the acknowledgment.
The month only becomes the month of
Ramadan when it is popularly
acknowledged by the vast majority of
people.
Sha Sha is only Sha when it becomes
popularly acknowledged by the vast
majority of people. There's no situation
where Muslim we have two or three folks
fasting over here while two or three
folks across the street are having aid.
This doesn't happen. It shouldn't
happen. It does happen physically
because of because of ignorance, because
of politics, because of whatever it is.
But this is not something that should
ever occur. Because fasting is when we
all fast.
And
breaking our fast is when we all break
our fast.
And slaughtering is when we all
slaughter.
That is the time with Allah
subhanahaala.
So we have here a narration on the
authority of
[Silence]
he says
fast
when you see the crescent. And notice
here how it is in the plural. He's
speaking to the plural. He's not
speaking to the individual. He says,
he's saying all of you fast when you see
the crescent and break your fast.
Meaning at the end of Ramadan, the
beginning of Shael, when you see the
crescent, meaning of Sha. And if it is
clouded
then
count then finish it or complete
the month to 30 days because a month can
only be maximum 30 days. 29 is the
shortest a month can be. 30 is the
longest a month can be. And so he tells
us sallallah.ai alaihi wasallam. The
spirit of the narration is that we fast
when we see the crescent. We break our
fast when we see the crescent. And if
there is hesitation,
if we are unable to see the crescent,
then we do not begin fasting until we
either see the crescent or we reach 30
days. Those are the two instances where
the month of Ramadan would be considered
to have commenced. We'll get into how
many people need to see the crescent for
it to be a valid sighting. But the point
here is that the month of Ramadan
commences in one of two ways. Number
one, the crescent is witnessed and that
and that sighting is accepted by the
community. or two 30 days of Shaan
conclude and you know by deduction it
has to be Ramadan the next day. These
are the two instances these are the two
ways that we would affirm the month of
Ramadan and it is in the plural. So he
tells us
And so
why is it that
we do not assume just to be safe?
We do not assume
it to be 29 days.
Right? So so
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam tells
us if when you see it fast when you see
the crescent for sha break your fast.
Okay, this is clear. Then he tells us,
"And if there is hesitation,"
meaning that there are clouds
obstructing the sighting of the moon or
whatever else may obstruct the sighting
of the moon, then we are to
continue for 30 days of Shabbat. Why not
make it
Ramadan?
just to be safe. The crescent could
be hiding behind those clouds right now.
Why is it then that we don't play it
safe and start Ramadan at 29 days of
Shaan?
And that is because
this is a principle across the board
when it comes to
in general but specifically
in citing here.
He tells us, this principle tells us
that
something does not end or begin until we
have evidence for it. And we can use
this principle for many other things.
Let's say we had two timets for salah.
One says that fud comes in,
you know, at 6. The other says fud comes
in at 6:10. Which one do we go with?
Based on this,
the earlier or the later?
Huh?
The earlier. Why? To be safe. But that's
exactly the opposite of what we're
taught here in this narration, isn't it?
Right.
We go with the later. We always go with
the later. Why? Because something does
not commence by suspicion.
It doesn't commence by being safe. It
only commences by way of clear evidence
or deduction.
Otherwise, it doesn't commence. We
always go with the later calculation.
And that goes for the months, the years,
the days, and even the hours, and the
times for salah. The times for salah, we
always go with the later. Why? Because
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]